l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion du projet loi portant
transposition de la Cour nationale
interprofessionnel relatif au partage de
la valeur au sein de l'entreprise hier
soir l'assemblée a continué l'examen des
articles s'arrêtant à l'amendement 38
portant article additionnel après
l'article 14
et donc pour le défendre l'article 38
il n'est pas défendu le 108
n'est pas défendu le 31
n'est pas défendu le
364 monsieur Lucas vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente ravie
d'inaugurée avec vous cette matinée sur
ce texte je vous propose avec cette
amendement de facilité le départ en
vacances par le financement de chaque
vacance avec les droits au titre de la
participation aux résultats de
l'entreprise et les sommes affectées à
un plan d'épargne salariale en leur
faisant bénéficier des exonérations déjà
prévues dans le code du travail pourquoi
cette amendement parce que je crois que
c'est aussi la qualité du repos qui
donne de la valeur au travail c'est le
temps libéré qui permet souvent bien des
réparations du temps contraint celui du
travail vous le savez sans doute je
milite avec d'autres collègues pour le
droit aux vacances 83 ans après Léo
Lagrange et les congés payés 20 ans
après la loi de 1998 contre l'exclusion
qui consacre ce droit en vacances comme
un objectif national cet été ce seront
près de quatre Français sur 10 qui ne
pourront pas partir en vacances c'était
au moment de la loi de 98 que j'évoquais
il y a un instant trois Français sur dix
ce chiffre il n'est pas homogène dans la
société vous vous en doutez bien puisque
chez les 20% des plus riches là ce
seront 80% qui partiront en vacances cet
été nous devons agir parce que le droit
aux vacances je le dis c'est un droit au
repos à la réparation après une année de
travail c'est la possibilité de se
retrouver en famille de respirer c'est
bon pour la santé psychologique de nos
concitoyens c'est bon pour la réussite
éducative des enfants des salariés parce
que quand on revient à la rentrée
scolaire en ayant bénéficié de ces
vacances on a pu développer son
imaginaire sa confiance en soi et ainsi
affronter un certain nombre d'épreuves
scolaires voilà la proposition que je
formule avec cet amendement dont je ne
doute pas qu'il recueillera un avis
extrêmement favorable surtout à
l'approche du moins de juillet alors
Monsieur Lucas que vous soyez d'accord
pour nous présenter le 360 396 également
non après et bien alors Monsieur
rapporteur votre avis sur l'amendement
364 merci beaucoup défavorable
j'entends votre combat il est légitime
simplement juste quelques points de
précision il y a eu effectivement la loi
que nous avons voté l'année dernière en
a permis le déblocage anticipé voilà
dans une dans une limite dans un certain
montant c'est moins 1% du stock qui a
été qui a été décaissé donc en fait
c'est relativement limité et par
ailleurs vous le savez il y a un certain
nombre de cas qui sont prévus de
déblocage anticipé auquel on a rajouté à
la suite dans l'amendement que nous
avons voté à l'initiative de la
Commission des financières des travaux
pour financer la rénovation énergétique
je remercie monsieur le ministre vous
avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés c'est le même avis que
monsieur le rapporteur les partenaires
sociaux n'ont pas prévu ce qu'elle a ils
ont prévu trois supplémentaires à chaque
PLF et plffc sont on a beaucoup de
débats sur l'utilisation de ce type de
fond avec la volonté de bien
circonscrire les possibilités
d'utilisation les partenaires n'ayant
pas ouvert ce champ la vie est
défavorable et il sera défavorable pour
les mêmes raisons sur le 396 je vous
remercie alors Monsieur Lucas vous avez
la parole
donc je vais mettre au revoir
l'amendement avec un double avis
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté vous
avez la parole sur le 396 monsieur Lucas
merci merci madame la Présidente bon là
c'est un amendement de repli mais le
ministre avant même d'entendre mes
arguments à exprimer son avis
défavorable c'est dommage que le
ministre du socle est oublié un peu vite
des combats qu'il a pu porter dans une
famille politique qui est celle qui a
construit les congés payés qui a
construit l'éducation qui a accompagné
le développement des mouvements
d'éducation populaire des auberges de
jeunesse et que avec son retournement de
veste il est également retourné ce
principe essentiel qui est que le sens
de la République depuis deux siècles
c'est de se battre pour le temps libérer
pour le droit au repos je vous l'ai dit
par votre inaction ce sont encore des
milliers de familles qui cet été
n'auront pas droit au petit moment de
répit au petit moment de bonheur vous
leur avez infligé cette année une
réforme des retraites injuste brutale
vous leur affligez à chaque discussion à
chaque texte je pense par exemple aux
allocataires du RSA des coups de
matraque socio en permanence on vous
demande simplement là quoi de leur
permettre un peu de répit un peu de
bonheur pendant la période estivale
comme nous allons nous pouvoir en
profiter nous qui faisons partie des 20%
des Françaises et des Français les plus
riches et qui avons le privilège de
partir en vacances vous auriez pu sur
cet aspect là avec cet amendement là de
repli qui est indolore économiquement
faire un geste pour montrer que entre
les paroles les belles déclarations et
les actes et bien il y a une cohérence
mais la cohérence chez vous c'est vrai
que ça fait longtemps qu'on l'achète
alors monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre vous
avez déjà indiqué des favorable j'ai
donc le métro va avec un double avis de
défavorable qui est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté l'article 15 nous
avons monsieur carolier
vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente donc cet
article promeut une meilleure
gouvernance des fonds en prévoyant que
dans le cas où les droits de vote liés à
un fond d'actionnariat salarié sont
délégués à une société de gestion de ce
fond cette société présente chaque année
au conseil de surveillance sa politique
d'engagement actionnariale de plus si la
société de gestion exerce le droit de
vote pour le compte de l'épargne salarié
la société a pour obligation de rendre
compte annuellement en conseil de
surveillance des fonds de sa politique
de vote lors des dernières assemblées
générales d'actionnaires
tout cela va dans le bon sens
car l'actionnariat salarié c'est aussi
une question de gouvernance et son
développement passe par une meilleure
association et une meilleure
participation des salariés actionnaires
à la gouvernance de l'entreprise
je vous remercie alors le premier
amendement alors attendez je vous
indique donc sur le vote de l'article 15
je suis saisi par le groupe renaissance
du demande de scrutin public est annoncé
dans l'ensemble de l'Assemblée nationale
et nous en arrivons à l'abonnement 78
monsieur Viry vous avez la parole
oui merci Madame la présente ça pourrait
penser que c'est un abonnement
rédactionnel mais ce n'est pas
uniquement de la rédaction c'est un
amendement qui effectivement demande à
clarifier une décision impactante et
justifiante l'article 15 conformément
l'année voilà un petit peu la motivation
de cet article qui invite effectivement
à une rédaction plus ambitieuse
non merci monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur cet amendement
merci madame la Présidente merci notre
collègue Viry pour cette pression
sémantique effectivement je pensais
qu'il était rédactionnel mais vous avez
effectivement bon je pense qu'on est
quand même dans une dans une nuance mais
que effectivement on peut on peut on
peut entendre donc je suis favorable à
maman je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
favorable également je vais donc le
mettre au voie avec un doc double à vie
favorable commission gouvernement qui
est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté le 182 de Madame SAS vous
avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente vous
savez pour les écologistes c'est très
important que cette épargne salariale
soit investie dans des fonds et qui ne
créent pas de dommages pour
l'environnement et l'objectif de cette
amendement et de préciser la disposition
prévue par l'article 15 actuel qui vise
à améliorer la transparence en matière
de politique d'engagement en effet cet
article prévoit que lorsque les droits
de vote liées à un fond d'actionnariat
salarié soit délégué à une société de
gestion de ce fond cette dernière doit
présenter chaque année au conseil de
surveillance sa politique d'engagement
actionnarial ainsi que le compte-rendu
de sa mise en oeuvre pour informer les
salariés épargnants afin d'assurer une
plus grande transparence nous proposons
ainsi de renforcer la lisibilité sur les
résultats obtenus par la politique
d'engagement de la société de gestion et
non seulement les moyens mis en oeuvre
notamment par la communication au
conseil de surveillance de quelques
indicateurs lui permettant d'évaluer
l'efficacité de cette politique
d'engagement cette précision est
nécessaire car actuellement bien que
l'article 29 de la loi logique climat
impose au gestionnaire d'actifs de
rendre compte de leur politique
d'engagement il n'existe aucune
obligation concernant le contenu de ce
reporting la mesure de transparence
proposée par cet amendement permettra
donc aux salariés de mieux évaluer
l'impact de la politique d'engagement et
de vote de leur gestionnaire d'actifs
sur la stratégie des entreprises dans
lesquelles ils ont investissent
notamment ce qui concerne les impératifs
climatiques
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis sur cet abonnement
oui merci beaucoup c'est un point
effectivement qu'on avait travaillé
ensemble
que vous portez que vous portez avec
avec force et convictions il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de
prérogative en tout cas d'obligation de
compte-rendu qui sont qui sont liés à la
composition des FCPE on en a un petit
peu parlé et notamment dans les rapports
annuels il y a évidemment l'inventaire
des dépôts l'inventaire des entreprises
dans lequel ils investissent ça va de
soi il y a un son il y a notamment
quelques règlements européens qui le
précisent et vous indiquez qu'il faudra
aller sans doute plus loin j'entends
bien les fondements d'ailleurs sur quels
sont les politiques de transition
énergétique des entreprises dans lequel
s'effont investissent
ça pourrait être une bonne idée sauf que
il faudrait vraiment qu'il fasse
eux-mêmes le travail de de monito de
monitoring ce serait sans doute en tout
cas ils en ont pas les moyens enfin ils
ont même pas accès c'est assez donné là
donc évidemment les valorisations tous
les éléments financiers ça va de soi
mais je pense que ce serait en tout cas
ce serait assez inopérant donc c'est
juste pour éclairer le le CET assemblée
il y a déjà pas mal d'informations qui
sont qui sont à la disposition dans les
règlements AMF et dans les dans les
rapports de gestion qui sont soumis aux
uns aux autres donc ce sera défavorable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie monsieur t'avait vous avez
la parole
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
toutes et à tous chers collègues pour
venir en soutien de l'amendement de
notre collègue et Vassas
effectivement c'est une exigence
minimale
qu'il s'agit de préciser de conforter si
on veut que ces dispositifs soient
d'abord pleinement responsable et qu'il
n'y ait pas comme c'est parfois le cas
un peu de tout ou des choses qui passent
un peu sous silence dans ces fonds-là et
par ailleurs nous allons entamer très
prochainement l'examen d'un projet de
loi sur l'industrie verte qu'il a aussi
à de grandes ambitions au moins sur le
papier en matière de labellisation verte
d'un certain nombre de dispositifs de
mobilisation de l'épargne privé et je
crois que si on veut que cet argent soit
vraiment
utile vraiment fléchés il ne faut pas se
contenter des règles existantes il faut
en préciser vraiment toutes les tendues
et les exigences qu'on peut y mettre en
termes de transparence en termes de
contrôle c'est à la fois un devoir par
rapport à ceux qui placent leur argent
mais c'est aussi une nécessité si on
veut être bien sûr que cet argent est
bien utilisé à ce pourquoi il est censé
servir
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix cet
amendement qui a un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement qui
est pour qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté je mets aux voix l'article 15
donc sur l'article mes chers collègues
merci de regagner vos places le scrutin
et tout vert
alors il est pas annoncé mais je l'ai
annoncé dans l'enceinte de la de la
de l'Assemblée le scrutin public est
annoncé effectivement il est pas affiché
voilà ça y est il est affiché donc le
scrutin clos vous avez comme ça vous
avez le temps de voter cher collègue
merci pour votre vigilance sur les sur
la fichage alors les votants 61 exprimés
56 majorités 29 pour 55 contre 1
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté nous en
arrivons à l'article additionnel après
l'article 15 et nous avons des
amendements qui peuvent être soumis à
une discussion commune le 85 monsieur le
député vous avez la parole merci madame
la présidente Madame la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre le présente un
abonnement est une demande de rapport en
lien à l'article 11 de la loi relative à
la croissance et la transformation des
entreprises je renvoie à la loi pacte de
l'article 11 de la victoire a instauré
l'obligation de la participation des
salariés tenant compte d'un calcul basé
sur l'effectif annuel des effectifs
salariés depuis son application cette
loi n'a pas été évaluée sur son
efficacité cet amendement prévoit
d'obtenir un rapport sur cet article au
plus tard un an après la promulgation de
la présente loi
et cela afin de réaliser un premier
bilan sur les atouts et faiblesses de ce
dispositif je vous remercie je vous
remercie
en
deux n'est pas des fendu le 123
et les défendus le 77
n'est pas défendu le 146 il est
défendu
[Musique]
et donc monsieur le rapporteur vous avis
je suis désolé j'ai pas compris ce que
vous me disiez monsieur
est-ce que vous pouvez prendre le 2 de
Monsieur Guedj est-ce qu'il a été adopté
par la commission il a été adopté par la
commission donc vous pouvez le reprendre
alors vos avis sur sur ces amendements
monsieur le rapporteur donc du coup
simplement pour dire parce que c'est des
amendements qui vont dans le même sens
et qui sont de rapport et le 2 de
Monsieur gage qui avait adopté en
commission et le mieux rédigé de tous
donc je vous propose d'adopter celui-là
qui effectivement va permettre de faire
un point utile donc nous aurons besoin
de pour éclairer nos travaux dans les
prochains mois et prochaines années et
défavorable du coup sur les autres
alors excusez-moi monsieur l'abandon
parce que je vais te coucher
mon attention a été appelée sur les
prochains scrutins publiques donc je
vais reprendre vos avis
sur le 123l 146 et favorable sur le
numéro 2 que j'ai repris je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente sur le
8523146 sur le 2 de Monsieur Guedj
repris par monsieur le rapporteur le
gouvernement est traditionnellement
défavorable aux demandes de rapport mais
puisqu'il était adopté par la commission
c'est un avis de sagesse
je vous remercie alors donc je vais
mettre au voie le premier amendement 85
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le numéro 2 donc un
avis favorable de la commission sagesse
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
il est adopté et il fait tomber les 123
et le
146 et donc je vous annonce que sur les
amendements 65 59 70 71 72 je suis
saisie par le groupe rassemblement
national d'une demande de scrutin public
est annoncé dans notre enceinte et nous
en arrivons à l'amendement 65
vous avez la parole
oui donc cet amendement 65 demande un
rapport sur l'opportunité de ce dont on
a parlé ces derniers jours donc de sur
la condition des cinq années
consécutives pour le seuil de
franchissement
des 50 salariés qui posaient problème et
remplacer le mot consécutif par moyenne
donc voilà c'est un amendement qui
demande un rapport dessus s'il vous
plaît
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteurs
qui contre
c'est inscrit un public excusez-moi je
vais trop vite
alors on n'a pas les 5 minutes est-ce
que vous souhaitez attendre cher
collègue
alors merci je vais le mettre au revoir
merci de regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos ça a fonctionné je
vous entends pas claquer les petites oui
ça a marché votant 51 exprimer 51
majorité 26 pour 11 contre 40 c'est
parce qu'il y en a plusieurs c'est pour
ça que vous maintenez vos petits
pupitres ouverts c'est très bien le 49
n'est pas défendu le 59 donc Monsieur
kerbrolier Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE donc là
aussi ça c'est un amendement qui revient
sur quelque chose dont on a longuement
parlé ces derniers jours c'est la
formule de calcul de la réserve spéciale
de participation donc cet amendement
demande un rapport
puisque ceci a souvent été demandé par
la copie ça on en avait parlé mais aussi
par Monsieur le Maire lors de la loi
pacte en 2019 donc je pense qu'il faut
quand même demander un rapport sur qui
permettra d'étudier la formule la plus
adéquate
merci monsieur le rapporteur oui c'est
satisfait par une disposition de
l'article 2 que nous avons adopté voté
donc demande de retrait si on est
favorable je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre mais ma vie vaut le maintenir
oui je vais donc je voudrais donc cette
inscrivent un public chers collègues je
vais le mettre au bois merci de regarder
vos places donc un double avis
défavorable qui le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
vos temps 50 exprimer 50 majorités 26
pour 11 contre 39 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté le numéro 70 l'amendement
70 monsieur carolier vous avez la parole
oui donc là
c'est un amendement qui demande là aussi
un rapport
destiné à étudier
l'opportunité de développer
l'information et le conseil dans les
entreprises auprès des épargnants
salariés
on pense que ça devrait
ceci devrait être dispensés par un
organisme forcément indépendant
indépendant de l'entreprise pour éviter
les conflits d'intérêt des organisations
syndicales et également des sociétés de
gestion de des OPCVM
et donc ce prestataire indépendant
pourrait être pris en charge
financièrement en faisant appel au
compte
personnel de formation des salariés et
l'entreprise elle pourrait prendre sa
part dans le financement de de ces
formations
au travers d'une
contribution financière qui couvre
partiellement le coup et qui serait
assimilé à des frais de formation
professionnelle
je remercie monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable monsieur le ministre mais ma
vie je vais donc le mettre au voie je
vous rappelle c'est un scrutin public
avec un double avis défavorable le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
vos temps 55 exprimés 55 majorités 28
pour 12 contre 43 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas un opté le 71 monsieur carolier
vous avez la parole
donc là cet amendement consiste à
inciter les salariés à conserver leurs
actions dans les PEE le plus longtemps
possible parce que la pratique devenue
fréquente d'une période d'acquisition de
trois ans non suivi d'une période de
conservation obligatoire fait que les
salariés non mandataires sociaux ont
tendance à considérer leur action comme
un complément de rémunération
donc l'amendement consiste en
contrepartie d'un engagement de
conservation de 8 ans sauf décès à
compter de l'acquisition définitive en
exonérerait de l'impôt sur le revenu au
titre des gains de session donc le
salarié qui conserverait ses actions sur
le long terme
donc cet amendement consiste à demander
un rapport destiné à examiner la
possibilité donc d'exonérer d'impôt sur
le revenu les gains de cession d'action
gratuite conserver au-delà d'un
engagement irrévocable de 8 années
par les salariés et les anciens salariés
non mandataires sociaux
défavorable également je vais donc le
mettre au revoir merci de regarder vos
places double avis défavorables ce que
tu en est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 62 exprimer 62 majorité 32
pour 12 contre 50 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté le numéro 72
chers collègues vous avez la parole
monsieur du ciné
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues c'est un moment consiste à
obliger une entreprise à offrir aux
autres salariés la possibilité de
souscrire chaque année à des actions
dans le cadre du ppee
à des conditions de prix analogue à
celle du cercle restreint des salariés
mandataires sociaux qui investissent au
capital et là je leurs actions
ordinaires ainsi obtenues dans un PEA
pour bénéficier d'une exonération
d'impôt sur la plus-value en effet le
PEA procure un avantage fiscal qui ne
paraît pas juste de réserver à une
minorité dans l'entreprise c'est
pourquoi une offre concomitante au prix
au même prix réservé aux autres salariés
dans le cadre du PEE répondrait un souci
d'équité et à l'objectif de renforcer la
part des salariés dans le capital de
leur entreprise c'est une mesure
d'équité d'égalité entre les salariés et
les et les patrons les chefs
d'entreprise qui peuvent bénéficier
davantage
merci
au revoir donc avec un double avis
défavorable commission gouvernement
merci de regagner vos places le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 60 exprimer 60 majorité 31 pour
12 contre 48 l'Assemblée nationale n'a
pas adopté
l'amendement 101 n'est pas des fendue le
madame la députée vous avez la parole
merci Madame Présidente je suis ministre
c'est amendement visé introduire un
rapport d'évaluation de la mise en
oeuvre de disposition de l'article 6 il
est essentiel de suivre et d'évaluer
l'impact de l'efficacité des mesures
prévues par cet article afin d'en
assurer l'efficacité et l'adéquation
avec les objectifs fixés je vous
remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
des favorable monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie je vais donc le mettre aux voix
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui contre il n'est pas adopté le 142
monsieur le député vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur ce
régime temporaire d'exonération totale
de toutes charges fiscale ou sociale
sous plafond de 3000 ou 6000 euros selon
l'entreprise institut en 2022 au
bénéfice de l'ensemble des salariés
percevant au moins trois fois le SMIC
devait expirer le 31 décembre 2023
deux salariés percevant la même
rémunération totale surveillant
attribuer la même prime pourraient alors
connaître des différences caractérisées
du davantage fiscal
enfin le bénéfice de ce dispositif est
uniquement déterminé en fonction de la
taille de l'entreprise ainsi un salarié
percevant une prime de partage de la
valeur d'une entreprise de 50 salariés
au moins bénéfice bénéficierez d'une
exonération de l'impôt sur le revenu de
la CSG de la scrds dans la limite d'un
plafond pouvant aller jusqu'à 6000 euros
alors qu'un salarié percevant la même
prime dans une entreprise de plus de 50
salariés ne pourraient bénéficier
d'aucune d'exonération fiscale pardon
dans ces conditions le Conseil d'État
estime que ces dispositions porte une
atteinte principaux principes d'égalité
devant les charges publiques c'est
pourquoi c'est amendement demande au
gouvernement de remettre Parlement un
rapport évaluant le potentiel d'atteinte
de cet article au principe d'égalité
devant les charges publiques je vous
remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre je vais donc le
mettre au voie avec un double avis
défavorable qui est pour qui contre il
n'est pas adopté le 269 qui le défend
monsieur Tavel vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente c'est une demande
de rapport qui fait quoi la discussion
qu'on vient d'avoir sur l'épargne
salariale et sur son véritable caractère
de financement de la transition
écologique puisque un certain nombre de
fonds existants et d'agence de
d'évaluation de ces fonds présentent des
lacunes qui nous semblent à minima
justifier que par ce rapport le
gouvernement puisse s'établir une
situation précise de l'utilisation de
ces fonds et notamment de la part de ses
fonds qui alimentent les énergies
fossiles ça nous semble être de bonne
politique que de pouvoir informer la
représentation nationale sur un élément
aussi important pour le respect de nos
objectifs climatiques
je remercie monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre j'ai donc le métro
voit avec un double avis défavorable qui
est pour qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté le 271
monsieur Tavel vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente là encore c'est
pour vous donner l'occasion de peut-être
rattraper quelque chose qui n'a pas été
fait hier dans la discussion sur
l'évasion fiscale et de pouvoir pousser
plus loin la manière et la réflexion sur
comment on peut faire en sorte que les
salariés lorsque il y a des stratégies
d'évasion fiscale qui sont pratiquées
par leurs entreprises et lorsqu'elles
sont mises à jour puissent d'abord
pleinement savoir de combien ils ont été
privés en intéressement ou en
participation essentiellement mais aussi
ensuite de comment on peut récupérer ces
sommes ça revient pas sur le débat
d'hier mais il me semble que ce rapport
pourrait permettre d'y voir plus clair
et peut-être de travailler ensuite
collectivement à une évolution de la
législation puisque vous sembliez dire
hier vous-même qui avait sans doute des
choses qu'on pouvait améliorer même si
celle qui était proposée ne vous
convenait pas
je remercie monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis
en allant on a laissé ses travaux et
j'ai même dit qu'effectivement que il
fallait sans doute qu'on les continue
bon mais on a quand même voté un rapport
donc je trouve que c'est bien c'est bien
pour pour cette loi puisqu'il s'ajoute
d'ailleurs à beaucoup d'autres qui sont
prévus dans les dans les lois
précédentes donc des favorable
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie j'ai donc le maître revoit
alors madame ça vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur vous dites qu'il faut
prolonger les travaux et la réflexion
sur les conséquences de l'optimisation
fiscale sur les dispositifs de partage
de la valeur particulièrement sur la
participation j'aurais voulu savoir
comment vous allez poursuivre ces
travaux et de quelle façon vous allez
pouvoir avancer sur ce sujet parce que
comme vous l'avez vu c'est la
préoccupation de nombreux salariés qui
attendent des réponses dans les
entreprises
[Musique]
alors je vais le mettre aux voix avec un
doigt vide défavorable qui est pour qui
est contre il n'est pas adopté le 392
vous avez la partie madame merci madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre en
cas d'optimisation fiscale le bénéfice
affiché par les entreprises et par
définition inférieures au bénéfice réel
cette sous-évaluation du bénéfice réel
grève le montant des participations ou
le montant ou le montant d'intéressement
versé aux salariés au titre du bénéfice
de l'entreprise le présent le
présentement de mon collègue
Jean-Philippe Tanguy demande la
production de rapport sur les
conséquences de l'optimisation fiscale
sur les dispositifs de participation et
d'intéressement je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre j'ai donc le métro
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté le
357 madame fasse que vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente c'est un
amendement de mon collègue Sébastien
Petavy avec cet amendement le groupe
écologiste propose un rapport sur les
risques de fragilisation de notre
système de retraite par répartition et
de substitution du salaire par des
mécanismes comme la prime de partage de
la valeur favoriser par la loi pacte et
par ce projet de loi d'abord ni ce texte
ni la loi pacte ne traite de
l'augmentation des salaires qui est
pourtant le premier et le plus juste
mécanisme de redistribution des
richesses dans l'entreprise
ensuite le groupe écologiste constate
que la loi pacte et ce projet de loi
cache à peine leur intention de
favoriser la retraite par capitalisation
en incitant à développer des dispositifs
tels que les plans d'épargne retraite et
en exonera en exonérant de cotisation
sociale les sommes qui sont versées ce
sont pourtant ces exonérations fiscales
qui prient de notre système de retraite
des ressources nécessaires pour garantir
à toutes et tous une retraite digne
alors face au risque qui pèse
vers une logique
actionnariale sur les salaires et la
retraite solidaire le groupe écologiste
s'aligne avec la demande de l'accord
national interprofessionnelle d'obtenir
un rapport sur les conséquences de la
loi pacte et de cette future loi
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre j'ai donc le métro
avec un double avis défavorable qui est
pour
qui est contre il n'est pas adopté nous
avons des amendements qui peuvent être
soumis à une discussion comme une le
premier le 87
vous avez la parole monsieur le député
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur monsieur le ministre nous
l'avons vu l'article 7 crée le plan de
valorisation de l'entreprise ce nouveau
dispositif de partage de la valeur
permet à tous les salariés ayant une
certaine ancienneté dans l'entreprise
dans bénéficier et ce nouvel élément
intéresse particulièrement et
financièrement l'ensemble des salariés
cet amendement de mon collègue Thierry
frappé permet d'obtenir un rapport sur
cet article plus tard un an après la
promulgation de la présente loi et cela
afin de réaliser un premier bilan sur
les atouts et les faiblesses de ce
dispositif je vous remercie
je vous remercie nous avons des AM
endements donc le 96 n'est pas défendu
et le 209 non plus alors monsieur le
rapporteur la vie sur le l'amendement 87
monsieur le ministre mais ma vie je vais
donc le mettre au voix avec un double
avis défavorable qui est pour qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté
d'accord alors nous avons des
amendements identiques le premier le 97
donc n'est pas des fendu le 211
n'est pas défendu nous en arrivons au à
d'autres amendements identiques 98 pas
défendu et le 200 braise non plus nous
en arrivons donc au titre et
l'amendement donc 272 monsieur rappelons
que vous avez la parole
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues la discussion sur ce projet de
loi touche à sa fin nous avons débattu
et défendu des dizaines d'abonnements
qui se voulaient pourtant d'améliorer le
texte mais comme d'habitude vous les
avez rejeté très peu ont été prises en
considération c'est dommage je regrette
que la question des salaires ne soit
toujours pas la priorité de la macronie
voire même tabou chez vous alors que
vous le savez bien c'est le salaire qui
assure le pouvoir d'achat la stabilité
des salariés la valorisation du travail
réalisé et nous avons aussi proposé que
cette intéressement ne soit pas
proportionnelle au salaire dans
l'entreprise mais quel mais quel que
soit la rémunération la prime devrait
être uniforme égale je regrette que
c'est un moment n'est pas été retenu
c'était une question de justice et
d'égalité pour le partage de la valeur
de l'entreprise la richesse de
l'entreprise est bien réalisée par tous
cité véritablement l'occasion de mettre
tout le monde au même niveau de
traitement une forme l'unité réelle dans
l'entreprise mais je surtout une pensée
pour nos territoires dit d'outremer
c'est là justement où les revenus le
pouvoir d'achat sont les plus bas et les
prix les plus élevés et vous le savez
tous le tissu économique est très
différent quid de l'effet de cette loi
dans nos territoires à mon sens quasi
voix nul j'espère que le chium le comité
intermédiaire des Outre-mer prochain
apôtres des mesures à nos spécificités
et que les questions des salaires de la
vie chère entrent seront abordés j'offre
rêver un peu par ailleurs le texte
prévoit que tous ces dispositifs soient
exonérés de cotisations sociales ce qui
aura pour conséquence d'assécher plus
encore les recettes de la sécurité
sociale comprenez que le titre actuel
n'est pas adapté ainsi le texte est
renommé visant à permettre aux
employeurs d'éviter les hausses de
salaire et appauvrir la sécurité sociale
alors merci monsieur le rapporteur des
faveurs monsieur le ministre même avis
j'ai donc le métro avec un double avis
défavorable qui est pour des contre il
n'est pas adopté il nous en arrivons aux
explications de vote et la première
prise de parole Monsieur François
Gernigon
oui merci madame la Présidente le groupe
Horizon est apparenté votre a évidemment
en faveur de ce projet de loi qui permet
une transposition législative fidèle de
l'accord national interprofessionnel
signé le 10 février dernier
si nous adoptons dans quelques minutes
ce projet de loi il s'agira d'une vraie
réussite pour la démocratie sociale
comme pour la démocratie parlementaire
nous aurons été digne de la confiance
que les partenaires sociaux ont placé en
nous
sur le fond ce projet de loi contient
des mesures extrêmement structurantes
qui permettront d'améliorer le partage
de la valeur dans les entreprises
participation dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés ouverture de
négociations pour partager la valeur en
cas de résultat exceptionnel prorogation
de la prime de partage de la valeur sous
conditions etc etc
transposer un accord national
interprofessionnel est toujours une
tâche compliquée je crois que nous y
sommes parvenus avec succès je veux
féliciter le rapporteur pour son
investissement et son écoute tout au
long de ce texte ainsi que Monsieur le
Ministre bien sûr le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera en faveur de ce projet
de loi je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Madame
ivassas
merci madame la Présidente c'est une
belle idée un bel objectif que celui du
partage de la valeur vous avez fait le
choix d'une transposition à minima d'un
accord interprofessionnel qui est un
premier pas et qui adresse le bon sujet
celui de l'accès aux outils de partage
de la valeur des salariés des
entreprises de 11 à 55 salariés pour
lutter contre un salariat à deux
vitesses d'un côté les salariés des
grandes entreprises déjà les mieux
rémunérés et qui ont accès à l’épendance
salariale et de l'autre ceux des TPE PME
qui n'y ont pas accès c'est un accord
qui aura une portée faible nous l'avons
dit qui n'a rien d'historique mais c'est
un accord signé par quatre
confédérations syndicales sur 5 et pour
les écologistes la démocratie sociale
est un bien trop précieux pour que nous
lisioposion le dialogue social la
démocratie sociale sont des piliers de
la démocratie on a touché du doigt avec
la crise des gilets jaunes et plus
récemment avec la lutte sociale unitaire
contre l'injuste réformé des retraites
l'importance des organisations
syndicales dans notre pays et plus
généralement des corps intermédiaires
diaires et je veux redire ici à quel
point les écologistes ils sont attachés
dans leur projet démocratique je veux
rendre ici hommage aux 2,5 millions de
salariés et agents syndiqués en France
qui ont le courage de défendre des
droits des salariés dans les entreprises
et les secteurs publics parfois au
détriment de leur évolution
professionnelle
et par respect pour leur engagement et
pour la signature de leur représentants
confédéraux les écologistes ne
s'opposeront pas à cette transposition
mais le travail du Parlement n'a pas été
à la hauteur de celui des partenaires
sociaux et c'est une terrible
occasion manquée nous aurions pu sur ce
projet de loi avancer sur un sujet
majeur la lutte contre les conséquences
de l'optimisation fiscale sur la
participation des salariés mais le
gouvernement le groupe Renaissance et
les républicains s'ils sont opposés
pourtant des milliers de ça derrière
chez McDo chez Procter chez Xerox chez
General Electric voit leur participation
réduite parfois à zéro par les pratiques
d'optimisation fiscale de ces grands
groupes et vous n'avez pas voulu ici
lever le verrou juridique qui les
empêche de se défendre qu'il est désarme
et les Bayonne alors parce que malgré
tout notre travail de conviction vous
n'avez pas eu le courage d'abroger cet
article qui protège les employeurs
malhonnêtes et malgré la bonne volonté
du rapporteur Louis Marguerite dont je
veux redire ici la qualité de son
travail parle mentaire le groupe
écologiste s'appionnera sur ce texte et
espère qu'au Sénat ou lors de travaux
ultérieurs nous pourrons enfin avancer
sur ce sujet et rétablir la justice pour
ces milliers de salariés qui attendent
l'abrogation de cet article unique je
vous remercie je vous remercie la part
les vingt ans à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
merci madame la Présidente
ce ministre monsieur le rapporteur même
la Présidente il y a un an ce
gouvernement débuté la session
parlementaire en nous soumettant un
projet de loi portant mesure d'urgence
pour le pouvoir d'achat ce texte ne
répondait absolument pas à l'urgence
exprimée par les travailleurs de notre
pays de se voir enfin un peu mieux
considéré par une augmentation de leur
salaire bien à l'inverse le gouvernement
sanctifiait la prime Macron en la
rebaptisant l'air de rien et indument
prime de partage de la valeur une prime
désocialisée qui est plébiscité par les
employeurs comme vous ne cessez de le
rappeler et pour cause elle est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur il peut décider
unilatéralement de l'accorder elle est
ponctuelle et son montant est aléatoire
et surtout elle évite soigneusement de
revaloriser les salaires bien entendu
les travailleurs n'ont pas été dupes et
le gouvernement n'est pas assez n'en
avait pas assez
alors le gouvernement a engagé les
partenaires sociaux à négocier un accord
afin de renforcer le partage de la
valeur au sein des entreprises le projet
de loi sur lequel nous devons nous
prononcer est une retranscription non
pas fidèle mais habile et même un peu
machiavélique de Lagny pourquoi parce
qu'en réalité les nos débats l'ont bien
montré la transposition de cette accord
national interprofessionnel aura très
peu d'effets pour les travailleurs mais
il permet à ce gouvernement d'entériner
sa doctrine contre les salaires et
contre notre système solidaire de
sécurité sociale avec ce projet de loi
le salaire qui est pourtant le premier
outil de partage de la valeur n'est plus
seulement contourné il est relégué aux
abonnés absents les organisations
syndicales avaient posé comme préalable
incontournable à l'équilibre du texte
l'inscription dans la loi du principe de
non substitution des primes de partage
de la valeur au salaire vous l'avez
obstinément refusé l'amendement du
rapporteur qui dit que la participation
ne peut être fiscalement et socialement
considéré comme du salaire ne répond
absolument pas à la demande des
syndicats que nous faisons notre or les
études qui montrent ces primes ce qui
montre que ces primes se substituent au
salaire fixent et à son augmentation
sont désormais nombreuses en 2022 les
versements de la PV la prime de la PPV
la prime de partage de la valeur ce
serait substitué à hauteur d'environ 30%
en moyenne à des revalorisations de
salaires vous avez même décrit l'ampleur
de cette substitution salaire dans
l'annexe 4 du PLFSS 2023 et les pertes
pour les ressources de la sécurité
sociale sont colossales elle s'élevait
déjà après de 1,7 milliards en 2021 et
comme ça ne suffit jamais vous avez même
créé un nouveau plan de partage dit de
valorisation de l'entreprise
censé fidéliser les salariés à leur
entreprise mais la seule chose qui fait
10 les salariés à leur entreprise ce
n'est pas un chantage la prime ce sont
de bonnes conditions de travail et un
salaire digne qui leur donne des droits
par ailleurs Emmanuel Macron avait
promis que les entreprises qui font des
super profits seraient obligés d'en
faire bénéficier les salariés vous
n'avez pas manqué de nous expliquer que
c'était un point qui avait été très
difficile à négocier au cours de la nid
entendons le patronat n'en voulait pas
heureusement le patronat a pu compter
sur votre soutien pour que le projet de
loi lui crée une échappatoire sur mesure
la seule obligation sera de négocier sur
comment définir une augmentation
exceptionnelle de bénéfices
monsieur Lecoq vous avez la parole
la seule obligation serait de négocier
sur comment définir une augmentation
exceptionnelle de bénéfices et en plus
si les négociations échouent c'est bien
ce qu'il se passera il ne se passera
rien la feuille de route que vous avez
donnée aux partenaires sociaux et votre
retranscription infidèle de l'accord
réponde avant tout à vos propres
intérêts pas à se détrailleurs et
surtout pas à ceux qui ont de faibles
salaires avec ce projet de loi vous
poursuivez encore la même obsession
faire du salaire un élément subsidiaire
oui c'est la prime des socialiser
défiscalisées au rang de première
contrepartie du travail et ce faisant
vous brisez le sens du travail parce que
le salaire première élément de
négociation du contrat de travail qui
vient en partie encadrer la
subordination du salarié à son employeur
installe la rémunération dans la durée
garantit des droits constituent un fil
rouge tout au long de la carrière
professionnelle ce projet de loi pour
terminer traduit votre vision d'une
société dont nous députés communiste et
ultramarin du groupe GDR nous ne voulons
pas une société toujours plus
inégalitaire au règne la loi de la
capitalisation nous nous défendons un
partage de la valeur qui doit être dans
l'entreprise ancrée avant tout sur le
salaire et qui doit surtout ancrer être
ancré dans la solidarité dans la justice
sociale dans la justice fiscale pour
l'ensemble de la société
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Michel Castellani
pour le groupe lot
merci merci
je veux dire d'entrée nous voterons en
faveur de ce projet de loi parce que
nous voulons envoyer un signal positif
en direction du dialogue social qui a
été quelque peu malmené ce dernier mois
et aussi parce que ce texte comporte un
certain nombre d'avancées pour favoriser
des outils de partage de la valeur dans
les entreprises nous avons cependant le
sentiment que nous sommes passés à côté
d'une belle occasion de mieux faire
cela gouvernance des entreprises sur la
conditionnalité des aides nous aurions
pu nous aurions dû aller au-delà de la
coordinaire
de façon qu'il faut regarder ce texte
avec
modération disons sans enthousiasme
excessif rien ne garantit qu'il se
traduira par des accords et des primes
automatiques un grand nombre
d'entreprises de salariés continueront
on le sait dans notre écarté
certains articles nous semblent bien
timides c'est le cas notamment pour la
prise en compte des bénéfices
exceptionnels on a beaucoup parlé alors
que l'on sait à quel niveau ils peuvent
grimper jusqu'à être conducteur
d'inflation
et puis cela a été aussi abondamment
souligné c'est presque tous les bancs
même si ce n'était pas l'objet de ce
texte
c'est par une politique salariale que
passe l'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat
les primes sont utiles à discutablement
mais elle ne peuvent se substituer au
salaire
cela étant noté très rapidement la
participation et l'intéressement
constitue des dispositifs qui nous
apparaissent juste qui nous apparaissent
positifs à la fois sur le plan des
ressources bien sûr mais également et
c'est très important sur la qualité des
relations entre le salarié et son
environnement professionnel voilà malgré
donc les réserves que je vais le
mentionner nous voterons ce texte je
vous remercie
je vous remercie d'avoir les maintenant
Monsieur David Amiel
merci merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues notre groupe était très
attaché à la transcription de la Cour
nationale interprofessionnelle et je
tiens à remercier le gouvernement et le
ministre Olivier du Sud pour la rapidité
et le scrupule avec laquelle elle a été
conduite et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous la voterons avec beaucoup
de détermination détermination à voter
d'abord un texte qui met en oeuvre
l'engagement de généraliser le partage
des bénéfices prix il y a un an par le
Président de la République et à la suite
par notre majorité détermination aussi à
voter un texte qui inscrit dans les
entreprises de 11 de plus de 11 salariés
un principe de justice quand une
entreprise gagne plus les salariés eux
aussi doivent gagner plus
détermination a voté un texte issu du
dialogue social constructif entre
organisation salariale et patronale et
qui apportera des progrès concrets à de
très nombreux travailleurs et nous
espérons donc que se dépassement des
postures déclivages que l'on a vu à
l'oeuvre dans la société sera aussi à
l'œuvre dans l'hémicycle
je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant Monsieur
Frédéric et cabrolier
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame le présidente alors nous
même si on regrette que vous n'ayez pas
en parallèle de ce projet de loi décidé
d'augmenter les salaires comme par
exemple le propose le rassemblement
national sur la base du volontariat
augmenter les salaires de 10% jusqu'à 3
fois du SMIC et en exonérant de charge
patronale même si il est clair que ce
projet de loi de partage de la valeur en
entreprise à un effet de substitution à
un effet de substitution sur les
salaires la paix essentiellement la
prime de partage de la valeur à hauteur
on l'a dit de 30% et un peu moins
l'intéressement mais qui a quand même
aussi un effet de substitution même si
on regrette que vous n'ayez pas à
l'occasion de ce projet de loi déterminé
ce qu'est un bénéfice exceptionnel
même si on regrette qui est rien sur la
fraude fiscale évaluer comme on l'a dit
à 40 milliards d'euros et c'est
transferts de profits se sont autant qui
échappent à la participation des
salariés et bien nous allons soutenir
nous avons soutenu ce projet de loi et
oui parce que nous sommes positifs nous
pensons avant tout à l'intérêt des
salariés français contrairement à laupes
et on se contente de ce que vous nous
donnez pour les salariés français alors
la prime de pour toi le pouvoir d'achat
à la prime la prime Macron vous l'avez
prolongé jusqu'à fin 2026 et vouloir
vous en faites un véritable dispositif
de partage de la valeur dans la durée et
bien ça pour nous c'est un gain de
pouvoir d'achat pour les salariés
on se voyait pas non plus à les contre
l'accord national interprofessionnel qui
effectivement
montre que il y a eu un accord
intersyndical à l'exception de la CGT et
donc c'est une ce projet de loi il est
vraiment une transposition à peu près à
90% de cet accord donc on est on tient
également nous à la démocratie sociale
et syndicale dont on ne voyait pas on ne
se voyait pas à les contre cet accord
enfin les augmentations d'action
gratuites pour les salariés font que on
va plus de souveraineté économique pour
les entreprises françaises et c'est ce
que demande le rassemblement national
depuis des années et puis ça va
impliquer encore plus les salariés dans
leur entreprise donc tout ça est positif
donc nous allons voter pour ce projet de
loi car nous votons dans l'intérêt des
travailleurs français et des salariés
français
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame
Marc
[Applaudissements]
puis madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales nous terminons trois
jours de débat ou finalement vous avez
préféré trahir Lagny plutôt que de
l'améliorer trois jours vous avez refusé
de parler d'augmentation des salaires
seuls et unique manière pourtant de
partager la valeur créée par les
salariés par tous les salariés des
entreprises dans un contexte d'inflation
féroce ou le salaire réel diminue vous
avez montré même si cela n'était
malheureusement pas approuvé de quel
côté vous vous situez évidemment celui
du patronat et du capital et évidemment
comme le rassemblement national nous en
a fait la démonstration partie de
l'arnaque sociale qui préfère lui aussi
verser des primes plutôt que d'augmenter
les salaires
alors vous nous parlez de démocratie
sociale et là c'est franchement
extraordinaire après six mois de
mobilisation massive dans notre pays où
vous avez refusé d'écouter de négocier
et même de recevoir les syndicats
l'ensemble des syndicats Unis en inter
syndicale et représentative de 93%
d'actifs opposés à votre réforme
idéologique et inutile des retraites qui
volent je le rappelle deux ans de repos
à tous les travailleurs et à toutes les
travailleuses
finalement la démocratie sociale c'est
bien quand ça vous arrange nous ne
sommes pas une chambre d'enregistrement
encore moins quand c'est le Medef qui
fixe les contours d'une proposition de
loi nous sommes des parlementaires et
nous sommes au côté de nos concitoyens
pour améliorer leur condition de vie
nous sommes élus sur un programme de
progrès nous sommes là pour porter la
voix de celles et ceux qui dans leurs
entreprises s'organisent et se battent
pour augmenter leur salaire comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui dans la grande
distribution comme c'est le cas Ikea au
terme de Vichy à Disneyland ou encore
dans de nombreuses entreprises et je
veux rendre hommage à toutes celles et
ceux qui s'organisent et qui se
mobilisent avec les organisations
syndicales pour augmenter justement les
salaires alors pourquoi nous disons que
les primes ne sont pas la solution on la
répété longuement les primes remplacent
les salaires et ça c'est l'Insee qui le
dit à hauteur de 30%
. de plus elles sont aléatoires
reproduisent et même accentue les
inégalités salariales elles sont souvent
captées majoritairement par ceux qui
gagnent le plus elles sont
discriminantes pour les femmes qui
occupent je le rappelle à hauteur de 80%
des temps partiels et de manière souvent
bien contraintes
sans parler pour les femmes de leur
carrière hachée et des salaires qui sont
encore bien plus bas que ceux des hommes
et pendant ce temps bah le capital cap
bien tranquillement une part toujours
plus importante de cette valeur enfin
les primes sont exonérées de
contribution à la solidarité
avec elle vous créez les déficits de
demain depuis des mois le gouvernement
et la minorité présidentielle nous
expliquent que lesquels sont vides elles
sont vides et que nous allons au devant
d'une grande catastrophe pour cela vous
nous faites travailler deux ans de plus
mais vous créez vous méthodiquement les
conditions pour créer les déficits de
demain et vous courez vous coupez notre
solidarité nationale des cotisations
mais aussi l'état des recettes fiscales
alors Monsieur le Ministre durant tout
l'examen vous avez refusé de nous
répondre de répondre à nos questions
quel est le coût de ces exonérations
sociales et fiscales comment cela
va-t-il être compensé comment maintenir
les droits sociaux des Français et des
Françaises
ou alors dites nous quel droit sociaux
vous allez supprimer le débat des
remboursements des soins dentaires c'est
déjà annoncé pareil pour certains
médicaments mais merci de nous fournir
la vis complète des rotules qui nous
attendent
enfin monsieur le ministre vous nous
dites l'année rien que la nuit vous
n'avez cessé de nous répéter ça pendant
tout le débat mais c'est faux et vous le
savez vous n'avez pas de transcription
de l'annonce institution au salaire pas
de mention des métiers des métiers
repères pas de mention du versement
automatique des surplus d'intéressement
et de participation en cas de bénéfice
exceptionnel pas de mention bénéfices
exceptionnelles notamment préférant les
l'augmentation exceptionnelle des
bénéfices pour toutes ces raisons nous
votre compte et nous le redisons
augmenter les salaires et pas les
actionnaires
je vous remercie alors je vous annonce
que sur le vote de l'ensemble du projet
de loi je suis saisie par le groupe
renaissance d'une demande de scrutin
public qui est annoncée dans l'enceinte
de l'Assemblée nationale
et nous en arrivons maintenant
monsieur Stéphane Viry vous avez la
parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues au terme de nos débats
et des amendements proposés sur ce
projet de loi depuis lundi le groupe les
républicains comme je l'avais indiqué
lors de la discussion générale va
approuver ce projet de loi ce projet de
loi il est important il est pas parfait
je vais en dire quelques mots mais le
question majeure du partage de la valeur
des résultats économiques de
l'entreprise nous paraît un véritable
sujet à l'heure où la France est divisée
sur énormément de questions ou la
fracture sociale reprend force et
vigueur ou la classe moyenne est trop
souvent oubliée et alors qu'on va parler
massivement du plein emploi mais aussi
des questions de rémunération de salaire
il nous fallait impérativement anticiper
le débat en parlant du partage de la
valeur cet accord national
interprofessionnel a été signé quasiment
par tous les partenaires sociaux il nous
faut être conforme à cette volonté des
acteurs du monde du travail et
valider l'atterrissage qui était proposé
après tout en respectant cette année
monsieur le ministre on peut quand même
être effectivement émettre le regret que
sur un tel sujet on aurait pu on aurait
dû aller plus loin et tracer d'autres
perspectives car il y a un manifestement
comment dirais-je une dichotomie entre
les entreprises qui gagnent de l'argent
et celles qui ne gagne pas d'argent ce
qui fait que les salariés de ces
entreprises qui sont en difficulté ne
bénéficieront pas par nature d'une
revalorisation de leur rémunération ou
de la récompense de leur travail il y a
également une deuxième différence entre
les entreprises de plus de 11 salariés
et les autres donc c'est un texte qui
effectivement oublie un certain nombre
de travailleurs et de travailleurs et ça
ça peut que nous laisser insatisfait je
vous ai dit également toutes les
réserves que nous émettons sur la
question du rachat d'action on est dans
l'ordre du symbolique j'aurais aimé
j'aurais préféré sur un sujet de société
comme celui-ci que notre pays puisse
aller au-delà parce que là aussi on peut
créer une autre fracture avec des
conséquences collatérales et puis
peut-être également une autre un autre
bémol à notre regret il y a eu faut-il
le dire et le reconnaître un excellent
travail préparatoire le rapport
d'information de nos collègues
Marguerite tessas déposaient il y a
quelques semaines en avril 2023 qui ont
tracé des idées qui ont fait des
propositions qu'on véritablement donner
une ambition sur ce sujet
on n'est pas comment dirais-je je trouve
qu'on aurait pu se servir davantage de
ce travail parlementaire dans le cadre
d'une action de législative postérieure
on aurait pu tout en conservant l'esprit
de la nuit se servir de ce travail fruit
de députés de sensibilité différente
mais qui ont moins en congé pour dire
sur la question du partage de la valeur
voilà où la France peut aller dans
l'intérêt à la fois des entreprises mais
également des salariés je pense
réellement qu'on a oublié ou qu'on est
passé à côté à côté de du sujet mais je
voudrais terminer ces quelques mots
postes postéance par par une observation
sur la tenue des débats on a vu que de
façon structurelle et pourquoi pas parce
que c'est ça la démocratie c'est ça la
démocratie parlementaire il y avait de
façon étayée désormais des visions très
radicales de la société de l'avenir du
pays on nous avons des collègues qui
cherchent à réactiver la lutte des
classes nous avons des collègues qui
effectivement remettent en cause avec
force et vigueur
quand même une marché on a des collègues
qui ne supportent pas l'idée même du
capital et qui voudrait donc transformer
profondément la France nous au niveau du
groupe les républicains nous sommes en
soutien de l'école marcher parce que
c'est la seule économique depuis des
siècles a prouvé son efficacité à la
fois pour la croissance du pays et pour
pour le fonctionnement de notre modèle
social c'était une observation que je
voulais dire au terme de ces débats
parce que je ne doute pas un instant que
cette version vision différente que nous
avons de la société ne cessera de se
réactiver tout au long des semaines à
venir et pour ma part j'ai cette vision
probablement golienne d'une autre façon
de concevoir le pays où la cohésion
nationale du pays est recherchée où le
respect de nos institutions et préserver
et on cherche toujours à sortir du
conflit dans l'intérêt de chacun
je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Anne Bergans
la présidente ce débat aura permis de
mettre en évidence des divergences
flagrantes de points de vue et c'est un
euphémisme sur le partage de la valeur
et plus largement sur la réalité des
entreprises leur gestion et leur
pérennisation qui ne doit pas opposer
salarié et entrepreneurs la nuit est un
texte de consensus et je le rappelle ce
consensus n'allait pas de soi il est le
fruit de plus de 4 mois de négociations
difficiles pour réussir à s'entendre sur
cet équilibre entre intérêt des salariés
et des entrepreneurs par respect pour
cette démarche nous ne devions d'être
fidèles à cet accord mais s'il pouvait
être tentant de la mender je tiens à
féliciter le rapporteur Louis Marguerite
et les différents groupes qui ont eu à
cœur de respecter le texte d'origine
respecter ceux qui l'ont négocié et
surtout respecter ceux qui en seront
bénéficiaires je tiens également à
rappeler que nous n'avons pas toujours
été habitués à avoir une démarche de
dialogue social en France mais rien ne
demeure jamais figé partenaires sociaux
ont su nous prouver
les vertus du dialogue social Lagny est
la preuve que ce dialogue social est
possible et il ne s'agit pas là d'une
exception pour rappel trois textes ont
été signés en 5 mois par les partenaires
sociaux chers collègues dont un dernier
texte sur les maladies professionnelles
et les accidents du travail qui a été
signé ce mardi par les organisations
syndicales et patronales une telle
unanimité rare dans ce type d'exercice
et nous l'espérons nous espérons que
cette dynamique va perdurer le groupe
démocrate vous l'aurez compris attentif
au dialogue social et à la justice
sociale se félicite de cette
transposition fidèle et votre a bien
entendu en faveur de ce texte je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant de Jérôme Guedj
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur s'il
fallait trouver un mot pour qualifier
les trois jours de débat ce serait
assurément frustration la frustration
est originelle elle procède de la
manière dont vous avez décidé de
transposer cette année nous l'avions dit
dès l'ouverture des débats en faisant le
choix d'une d'un projet de loi de
transposition de la nuit au lieu comme
vient de le dire mon collègue Stéphane
Viry de profiter de ce texte consensuel
élaboré par les partenaires sociaux pour
considérer qu'il pouvait constituer un
socle à partir duquel les parlementaires
pouvaient opérer un travail
d'enrichissement nous étions tous
demandeurs d'un texte de remise en cause
du partage de la valeur et pour cela il
fallait que dès l'origine vous
admettiez que le document d'orientation
que vous avez adressé aux partenaires
sociaux
cadenasser la nature même de l'accord
que vous appelez de vos vœux et donc
vous nous avez mis d'emblée dans une
situation de piège en disant aux
partenaires sociaux nous vous invitons à
travailler sur le partage de la valeur
mais voilà les sujets que nous vous
proposons d'aborder et en creux ce que
nous refusons que vous apportiez
si nous n'avons pas pu parler
aujourd'hui ou depuis ces deux jours de
salaire
de
la manière de partager les richesses
dans l'entreprise et notamment d'éviter
la substitution entre les primes et les
rémunérations et les cotisations
sociales qui sont rappelons-le le cœur
de la rémunération du partage de la
valeur s'ils ne vont pas pu le faire
c'est parce que vous d'emblée vous avez
exclu cette orientation dans le document
d'orientation vous avez transmis ce qui
me permet de dire on a essayé dans ce
débat de faire avancer quelques idées et
je vais vous le dire ici un peu
solennellement monsieur le ministre et à
nous collectivement je nous fais une
suggestion collective parce que nous
avons bien vu qu'entre démocratie
sociale et démocratie parlementaire nous
étions nous-mêmes complètement contraint
par le processus que vous avez retenu et
de dire nous transposons fidèlement la
nuit rien que la nuit et nous pouvons
rien faire d'autre et que le Parlement
se transforme en chambre
d'enregistrement la proposition que je
vous fais la suivante
désormais monsieur le ministre pourquoi
quand l'exécutif propose aux partenaires
sociaux de travailler sur un thème
pourquoi le document d'orientation ne
procède uniquement de l'exécutif
pourquoi nous ne pourrions pas avoir
dans cette émission pour mettre au début
du processus la démocratie parlementaire
un débat sur le contenu du document
d'orientation que le gouvernement
adresse aux partenaires sociaux et se
faisant je suis prêt à te mettre dans ce
cadre là puisque nous aurons eu en amont
le débat sur les thèmes que nous
souhaitons mettre au
débat des partenaires sociaux nous
aurions eu nous aurions mieux accepter
les choses je souhaite que nous
puissions travailler dans cette
orientation la deuxième frustration
évidemment elle est que justement vous
vous en êtes tenu à cette transposition
dont vous nous dites quel est fidèle
alors c'est vrai que 10 des 15 articles
n'ont pas du tout été modifiés alors
même que vous nous aviez dit qu'on
pouvait essayer de corriger les trous
dans la vous avez refusé tous ceux des
amendements que nous avions proposé qui
était fidèles à la nuit je pense à la
non substitution mes collègues l'ont
déjà évoqué à la question des métiers
européens vous avez par ailleurs refusé
tous ceux des amendements qui
permettaient de compléter alors c'est
vrai en transgressant avec votre règle
un peu absolu de lannir et un clany nous
avons toujours dit la nuit mais pas
uniquement mais pas uniquement la nuit
et nous avions fait des propositions sur
les minima conventionnelles sur
l'encadrement des salaires sur la
conditionnalité des exonérations
sociales j'espère que l'ensemble de ces
débats pourront se prolonger parce que
j'y ajoute une autre frustration c'est
que toutes ces perches qui vous ont été
tendues ont été accueillies je vous le
dis monsieur le ministre avec un peu
désinvolture voilà vous aviez une
réponse mécanique qui consistait à dire
je ne réponds pas à votre proposition
parce que ce n'est pas dans la nuit et
moi je suis ici le gardien zélé de
l'accord de Lagny et et refusant d'une
certaine manière le débat avec
l'ensemble des
parlementaires alors vous le voyez il y
a une frustration il y a une frustration
parce que nous aurions aimé faire plus
mais dans le même temps nous assumons au
groupe socialiste que le dialogue social
nous devons l'entretenir le chérir et le
valoriser à chaque fois qu'il permet
d'aboutir c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous voterons ce texte de transposition
mais nous le voterons pour saluer le
travail du dialogue social et
certainement pas pour saluer la manière
dont le gouvernement l'instrumentalisent
voir la manière dont il l'a méprisé
pendant le débat sur les retraites
alors je vais donc mettre au revoir le
projet de loi
merci de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 147 exprimé 137 majorité
70%, 27 l'Assemblée nationale a adopter
alors monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente je pars
faire les débats et je voulais juste
ajouter quatre points avant que tout le
monde parte pour soit sa circonscription
surtout pour le débat suivant qui sera
évidemment au moins aussi intéressant et
très important d'abord remercier cette
assemblée pour pour le vote favorable je
crois que c'est un très très bon message
qu'on vient d'envoyer à la démocratie
sociale regretter vraiment qu'on n'est
pas pu se retrouver au moins sur
certains articles tous ensemble moi j'ai
pas compris pourquoi on sait pas tous
retrouvés de façon unanime sur l'article
3 qui donne des nouveaux droits aux
salariés des entreprises de 11 à 49
salariés sur l'article 10 qui rehausse
les droits sur les plus bas salaires sur
l'intéressement et il y avait d'autres
dispositions comme cela c'est c'est
vraiment dommage remercier évidemment le
ministre ces services son cabinet la
direction générale les différents
directions générales qui se sont à
beaucoup mobilisés les services de
l'assemblée qui font un travail
formidable et qui sont toujours derrière
nous et tous nos collaborateurs et puis
surtout les syndicats et les
organisations patronales qui évidemment
sont à qui ont permis qu'on ait ces
débats riches pendant trois jours et
également ma collègue et Vassas que je
salue et vraiment l'excellent travail
qu'on a fait ensemble et dire
qu'évidemment on peut être frustré par
le débat on peut j'entends évidemment le
fait que certains points n'aient plus
n'est plus pas moi mais pas d'autres
mais certains ont pu l'exprimer bien
évidemment mais dire que il faut
capitaliser sur ce qui marche et on
vient tous et je pense qu'on a au moins
partagé cela c'est le le souci de faire
mieux de faire mieux pour nos
concitoyens dans tout ce qu'il traverse
et et nous le savons bien et donc
vraiment capitalisons sur ce qui marche
bien sûr qu'on aurait pu aller plus loin
sur tel ou tel point mais je crois que
en envoyant le signal qu'on veut que
nous venons d'envoyer en adamtant très
largement en première lecture ce texte
je crois qu'on peut vraiment envoyer le
le signal que il y a des choses qui
marchent qui a la démocratie qui
fonctionne la démocratie sociale la
démocratie parlementaire et que c'est
vraiment de très très bonne augure pour
la suite je vous remercie madame la
Présidente
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]